[російською] Історично волоський горіх
вирощується на 7% земель світу.
[російською] І Україна якраз має, мабуть,
найбільший у світі обсяг територій,
[російською] що підходять для вирощування
волоського горіха.
[російською] Це величезний потенціал,
яким взагалі ніхто не користується.
[російською] Тут мішаний сад — тобто,
ми маємо фундук і волоський горіх.
[російською] Волоський горіх росте
через десять метрів, фундук — через п'ять.
[російською] Сенс такої розсадки у тому, що ми
волоський горіх підіймаємо високо догори,
[російською] а фундук опускаємо донизу,
тобто вони можуть співіснувати.
[російською] Так, на одному гектарі більше
культур, до того ж різних,
[російською] що дає можливість, власне, позбутися ризиків.
[російською] Бо найголовніший ризик — відсутність
урожаю у кінці року через погодні умови.
[російською] Ми були першими в Україні,
хто застосував мішану модель,
[російською] всі думали про це,
але ніхто не хотів спробувати.
[російською] Основною метою було побудувати
дещо з вертикальною інтеграцією.
[російською] Тобто, з самого початку не було метою
посадити сад лише для продажу сировини.
[російською] Ми довгий час експортували волоський горіх
[російською] і розуміли, що ринок, в першу чершу,
продукту — цікавіший.
[російською] Ми бачимо тенденцію в світі до того,
[російською] що всі хочуть здоровий продукт,
корисний продукт, «healthy»,
[російською] і ми якраз у цьому тренді й просуваємося.
[російською] Ми виготовили енергетичну пасту —
це суміш волоського горіха з медом у вигляді пасти.
[російською] І з цією пастою виходитимемо
на світовий ринок.
[російською] У нас тут буде вологий цех.
[російською] Тут буде все митися.
[російською] Тут буде сухий цех — тут буде сушитися,
а там будуть дрібні сушилки.
[російською] Тут також буде виготовлятися паста.
[російською] Світові лідери — це Китай і Каліфорнія.
[російською] Каліфорнія дуже оригінальним чином
отримала свої сорти.
[російською] У нас була така станція у дендропарку
Веселі Боковеньки Кіровоградської області.
[російською] Це батьківщина американського горіха.
[російською] І на основі наших українських форм американці
вивели свої еталонні сорти, так званий «Chandler».
[російською] Але в американців є одна суттєва проблема —
він у них у природних умовах не росте.
[російською] Тому вони вирішили її, прищеплюючи
на коріння чорного волоського горіха,
[російською] умовно, наші сорти українського горіха.
[російською] І загалом вони результату досягли.
[російською] Наші ж довгий час намагалися
виростити в Україні американських горіх.
[російською] Але навіщо цим займатися,
якщо є українська селекція, на яку були витрачені роки?
[російською] Таких центрів тільки два:
в Україні та Молдові — більше ніде не було.
[російською] База нашої Придністровської станції,
в принципі, була для розвитку основною.
[російською] Але, на жаль, це залишилося незатребувано.
[російською] І розуміючи цю проблему,
ми, офіційні представники станції,
[російською] ми маємо ліцензію на розмноження
українських сортів, ми зараз активно цим займаємось,
[російською] тому що виступаємо
все-таки за українську селекцію.
[російською] Ми вважаємо, що в Україні мають
вирощуватися українські сорти,
[російською] не лише через здоровий націоналізм,
[російською] а й принаймні тому,
що це розумно, це правильно,
[російською] це було науково перевірено
і, у першу чергу, ризики відсутні.
[російською] Взагалі, народився і виріс я в Молдові.
[російською] За національністю я гагауз.
Тут якраз за річкою — Батьківщина.
[російською] Але я вже більше українець, аніж гагауз.
[російською] У студентські роки приїхав вчитися
до Одеси, так тут і лишився.
[російською] Місце було вибрано випадково —
я дізнався, що тут є ділянка землі у продажу.
[російською] І на цьому місці, власне,
пропонували вирити кар'єр.
[російською] Я приїхав подивитися, мені сподобалось,
[російською] і я вирішив, що ні,
кар'єра тут не буде — ми тут посадимо сад.
[російською] Це була закинута ферма, після розвалу
колгоспа залишились корпуси, які ми змогли врятувати.
[російською] Це схил — і для традиційного сільського
господарства це не дуже цікаво,
[російською] тому що ґрунтовий шар змивається донизу,
[російською] а для горіха, навпаки, підходить,
тому що він запилюється вітром,
[російською] і нам не обов'язково, аби вітер був з усіх боків,
[російською] тому для нас схил — це ідеально,
саме те, що ми й шукали.
[російською] Наразі ми продовжуємо
вести політику входження в село.
[російською] Це непросто: чуже село,
приймали нас нелегко.
[російською] І сьогодні нас не люблять —
вважають загарбниками, олігархами,
[російською] але це нормального для місцевого населення.
[російською] Вони неготові сприймати щось нове.
[російською] Головна проблема цих культур, яка й відлякує
потенційного інвестора, — це довготривале очікування.
[російською] Максимум, що ми можемо досягти, —
це врожайність, що настане на сьомий-восьмий рік.
[російською] Тому про можливість отримати
підживлення зі сторони, насправді, немає мови,
[російською] тому правильний шлях — лише кооперація.
[російською] Це хороший, зрозумілий шлях,
ми в ньому вбачаємо велику перспективу.
[російською] У кооперативі нараховується
близько 10 членів,
[російською] тобто тих, хто придбав у нас землю,
на якій ми вже посадили для них сад.
[російською] Сьогодні ми вже привозимо туди
студентів сільськогосподарських ВНЗ,
[російською] показуємо їм, ми відкриті —
готові ділитися, розповідати.
[російською] Ми не робимо з цього якихось секретів,
супертаємниці, навпаки, мені цікаво, щоб це розвивалося.
[російською] Якщо ця галузь розвиватиметься,
буде більше сировини
[російською] і ми зможемо створювати
більше спільних проектів з переробки горіхів.
[російською] Адже на скільки ж вистачить моїх сил?
[російською] Я не можу посадити 10 тисяч гектар,
а тисяча людей — можуть.
[російською] Тому для нас розвиток
в цьому руслі найпріоритетніший.
[російською] Тому ми намагаємось це популяризувати —
тобто, якщо люди це бачать, бачать, що це реально,
[російською] можна побачити наживо, як це росте,
можливо, це надихатиме людей займатися цим.